Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件正在发生的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师Lisa Johnson共同发起的“递归收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, ever wondered why finding the right therapist is an
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会直接赢取由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，你是否想过为什么找到合适的治疗师是
absolute game changer? Well, buckle up because in today's episode, we're diving deep into the crucial reasons why working with a qualified therapist can transform your life. Whether you're navigating personal challenges, seeking growth, or just aiming for a happier, healthier you, stick around because we're about to uncover the incredible impact a skilled therapist can have on your journey to mental well-being. Don't miss out on the insights that could shape your perspective. Hit that subscribe button, follow the show and let's get started on this empowering exploration together. Welcome to a special collaboration on the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I'm your host, Dr. Marianne Trent, Qualified Clinical Psychologist, and today I'm joined by the
绝对的转折点？系好安全带，因为在今天的节目中，我们将深入探讨与合格治疗师合作能够改变你生活的关键原因。无论你是在应对个人挑战、寻求成长，还是仅仅为了追求一个更快乐、更健康的自己，请留下来，因为我们即将揭示一位优秀的治疗师对你的心理健康之旅所能产生的不可思议的影响。不要错过这些可能重塑你观点的见解。点击订阅按钮，关注节目，让我们一起开始这场赋能的探索。欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》（Aspiring Psychologist）播客的特别合作节目。我是主持人Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，今天和我在一起的是
brilliant Dr. Tara Quinn-Cherillo from the Adversity Psychologist podcast as we team up for a joint episode. Exciting. Together, we're delving into a topic that impacts us all, finding a qualified therapist in the UK. Join us as we unravel the importance of this journey and share invaluable insights on navigating the world of mental health professionals. Whether you're an aspiring psychologist or someone seeking guidance, this conversation is packed with wisdom. Stay tuned for a thought-provoking discussion that might just change the way you approach your mental well-being. Let's dive in. I want to welcome you back Tara to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast and then of course this is a dual episode. Nice to have you and me together again it's lovely to see you thanks for having me. It is
来自《逆境心理学家》（Adversity Psychologist）播客的杰出嘉宾Tara Quinn-Cherillo博士，我们联手制作了这期联合节目。太令人兴奋了。我们将共同探讨一个影响我们所有人的话题：如何在英国找到合格的治疗师。加入我们，一起揭开这段旅程的重要性，并分享关于如何在这个心理健康专业人士的世界中导航的宝贵见解。无论你是有抱负的心理学家还是寻求指导的人，这次谈话都充满了智慧。请继续收听这场发人深省的讨论，它可能会改变你对待心理健康的方式。让我们开始吧。我想欢迎Tara回到《有抱负的心理学家》播客，当然，这是一期双重节目。很高兴你我再次聚在一起，见到你真好，谢谢你的邀请。确实是
so if people are listening from Aspiring Psychologist podcast we met in August 2022 when we were thinking about the kind of tricky issues of people being appropriately qualified to do what they say they can do, weren't we? Absolutely. It's that long ago, isn't it? So a little tiny seed has now grown into a wonderful thing to try and help people understand a bit more about that. It has. What has our seed grown into Tara? Oh this is so exciting and I can't believe we're actually going to say it. So we have written a book to help people understand. It's kind of two parts really aren't there? A little bit more about being qualified and regulated as a talking therapist in the UK but also to help you understand
所以，如果听众朋友们是从《有抱负的心理学家》播客过来的，我们是在2022年8月相识的，当时我们正在思考关于人们是否具备适当资格去做他们声称能做的事情这一棘手问题，对吧？绝对是。时间过得真快，不是吗？所以，一颗小小的种子现在已经长成了一件美妙的事情，旨在帮助人们更多地了解这一点。确实如此。我们的种子长成了什么，Tara？哦，这太令人兴奋了，我简直不敢相信我们真的要说出来了。我们写了一本书来帮助人们理解。它其实分为两部分，对吧？不仅是关于在英国作为谈话治疗师的资格和监管，也是为了帮助你理解
some things to look out for if you are going to be searching for a therapist or supporting someone else who's going to be searching for a therapist as well yeah and it is important because it's something that my friends and family ask me you know if I want to find somebody how do I even go about kind of climbing through wading through this quagmire what what do I look for how do I make sure someone is going to be safe and okay absolutely and if it's right to say one of the things that we've learned and we thought we were quite well versed in who's who and what professional bodies they're with there's a lot of little gaps um so we've worked quite hard to inform ourselves in order
如果你正在寻找治疗师，或者支持他人寻找治疗师时需要注意的一些事项。是的，这很重要，因为我的朋友和家人经常问我，如果我想找人，我该如何穿过这片泥潭？我该寻找什么？我如何确保某人是安全且可靠的？绝对是。如果说我们学到的一件事是正确的，那就是我们原以为自己很了解谁是谁，以及他们属于哪些专业机构，但实际上还有很多空白。所以我们非常努力地充实自己，以便
to be able to inform the public haven't we um it's not that easy to just go and find a therapist there are so many terms and they're so interchangeable it can be a bit of a a difficult path to navigate and for most people who might be looking for a therapist you might already be feeling quite unwell so that's an extra barrier to get over as well so I think that's why this book means a lot to us because we want to help people make that journey as easy and as safe as possible don't we yeah we do and I think sometimes just trying to you know find that last bit of energy in the tank to find someone almost interview them make sure they're going to be a good fit for you can be exhausting and I don't know about you but I've had experiences where some of my clients now
能够告知公众。并不是说随便找个治疗师就那么容易，有太多的术语，而且它们经常混用，这可能是一条很难走的路。对于大多数可能正在寻找治疗师的人来说，你可能已经感觉很不舒服了，所以这又是一个额外的障碍。所以我认为这就是为什么这本书对我们意义重大，因为我们想帮助人们尽可能轻松、安全地完成这段旅程，对吧？是的，我们确实想这样做。而且我认为有时仅仅是试图找到最后一点精力去寻找某人，几乎要面试他们，确保他们适合你，这可能会让人筋疲力尽。我不知道你怎么样，但我有一些现在的客户，
have been burned from getting the wrong therapist for them and then it's taken them years to kind of lick their wounds and then come back to it again so this is why getting it right first time or certainly the time that you're looking for that's why it matters isn't it yeah we talk about therapist fit a lot don't we so I always like to think of that on two levels so there's the fit between you and the individual is it someone you feel comfortable talking to you know is that person the right person for you personally because I sometimes work with people and the fit isn't right and that's okay but there's also that second level that actually is this person safe are they using a robust model are they qualified in what they say they are can you look them up that's the safety stuff that's
因为找错了治疗师而受到了伤害，然后花了几年时间来舔舐伤口，然后再回来尝试。这就是为什么第一次就找对人，或者至少在你寻找的时候找对人，这很重要，不是吗？是的，我们经常谈论治疗师的匹配度，对吧？我总是喜欢从两个层面来考虑：一个是关于你和个人之间的匹配，即你是否觉得和那个人交谈很舒服，那个人是否是你个人的合适人选？因为我有时和人合作，匹配度并不合适，那也没关系。但还有第二个层面，那就是这个人是否安全？他们是否使用稳健的模型？他们是否具备他们所说的资格？你能查到他们吗？这就是安全问题，
the risk stuff that's the kind of foundation for me and if you can have help with that then you can start to look at well actually is the fit okay and I think that's why our book's quite helpful because we're not just looking at where do you go to find people but we're helping people understand a bit more about those concepts aren't we and hopefully making that journey a little bit easier for them as well we certainly are and you know it's been a joy to work with you on this project you know you've been so responsive You've had to chase me a little bit here and there. Well, when we're both running busy practices, we both do all sorts of other things as well.
这就是风险问题，对我来说这是基础。如果你能在这方面得到帮助，那么你就可以开始考虑匹配度是否合适了。我认为这就是为什么我们的书很有帮助，因为我们不仅在看你去哪里找人，我们还在帮助人们更多地理解这些概念，对吧？并希望让他们的旅程变得稍微容易一些。我们当然是这样做的。你知道，和你一起做这个项目是一种快乐，你反应非常迅速。你不得不时不时地催促我。好吧，当我们都在经营繁忙的诊所时，我们也都还在做各种其他事情。
We both, I think the kind of common ground, if it's all right to bring that in the podcast, is we like to get good ethical, qualified information out to the public on all things emotional health, don't we? So this kind of came for us from some of that other work as well that you know we both do media work um this means a lot to us this isn't just about writing a book and getting information out there we care about people and we want them to have the right and the safe journey as well don't we we do i passionately care about people
我们俩，我认为共同点——如果可以在播客中提到的话——是我们都喜欢向公众传播关于情感健康的良好、合乎道德、合格的信息，对吧？所以这源于我们俩都在做的其他工作，你知道我们都做媒体工作。这对我们意义重大，这不仅仅是写一本书并发布信息，我们关心人们，我们希望他们拥有正确且安全的旅程，对吧？我们确实如此。我充满激情地关心人们
living distress-free lives and being able to feel better you know have that adaptive healing method that means that life doesn't feel like such a struggle um and I guess that's the bit that I want people to hang on to because some people might feel like this is elitist this is not us saying you must see a qualified psychologist. It's not that for me at all. It's make sure you know what you're getting and that someone is the right person to see you. Absolutely. I'm so glad you brought that up because as psychologists and we're both psychologists, different types of psychologists, which is also helpful for people to understand. This is not about elitism at all this is about us wanting to help protect the public because the you know when you listen to the podcast now what
过着没有痛苦的生活，能够感觉更好，拥有那种适应性的治愈方法，意味着生活不会感觉那么挣扎。我想这就是我希望人们坚持的一点，因为有些人可能会觉得这很精英主义。这不是我们在说你必须去看合格的心理学家。对我来说根本不是这样。而是要确保你知道你得到的是什么，并且某人是适合看你的人。绝对是。我很高兴你提到了这一点，因为作为心理学家——我们都是心理学家，不同类型的心理学家，这对人们理解也很有帮助——这根本不是关于精英主义，这是关于我们想要帮助保护公众。因为你知道，当你现在听播客时，
does the word therapist mean to you it can mean so many different things we're talking about talking very specifically but even within talking therapy there are so many different types of practitioners counselors um and we want to help people learn a bit more about that and post pandemic we've got a mental health crisis in the UK so more and more people we know that are reaching out. Where are they going? On top of that we've got a digital age now so more and more people are offering things online and in different formats. That's a lot to navigate even since I started my career 20 odd years ago. So where do you go? Where do you start? And sometimes if that seems really overwhelming, my concern is that people might not start that journey,
“治疗师”这个词对你意味着什么？它可以意味着很多不同的事情。我们谈论的是谈话治疗，但即使在谈话治疗中，也有很多不同类型的从业者、咨询师。我们想帮助人们更多地了解这一点。疫情过后，英国出现了心理健康危机，所以我们知道越来越多的人在寻求帮助。他们去哪里了？最重要的是，我们现在处于数字时代，所以越来越多的人在线上和以不同格式提供服务。即使在我20多年前开始职业生涯以来，这也有很多需要导航的地方。所以你去哪里？你从哪里开始？有时如果这看起来真的很让人不知所措，我的担心是人们可能根本不会开始那段旅程，
they may not reach out because it just seems too much. So we're hoping, aren't we, that this book might be bought by people like GPs, people that are going to be supporting people who might want to also look up a therapist, not just that individual member of the public. So if we can hopefully through our book, educate more professionals, get more conversations like this going. So we've, you know,
他们可能不会寻求帮助，因为这看起来太难了。所以我们希望，对吧，这本书可能会被全科医生（GP）这样的人购买，那些将要支持可能也想寻找治疗师的人，而不仅仅是公众中的个人。所以如果我们能通过我们的书，教育更多的专业人士，让更多这样的对话进行下去。所以我们，你知道，
we've liaised with different agencies that are in the book, haven't we? And the fact that we can all work together to help people understand a bit more about this and starting conversations is that's what we can do. We can all do that we're doing it right now aren't we well you're a master at that obviously with your conversation starter project but that's um another little passion project for you that um has really grown beautifully in 2023 so just in case people are listening like I don't know what that is
我们与书中的不同机构进行了联络，对吧？事实上，我们都可以共同努力帮助人们更多地了解这一点，并开始对话，这就是我们能做的。我们都可以做到，我们现在正在做，不是吗？好吧，你显然是这方面的大师，你的“对话启动者”项目，但那是你的另一个小激情项目，在2023年确实成长得很美。所以以防人们在听的时候不知道那是什么，
this is where Tara set up um with a friend and colleague of hers that people could just meet and walk and talk and have conversations. And it's it's grown to something beautiful. But yeah. So back to the book. What have we called it and where can people get it? What is our book called?'s called talking heads it's your guide to finding a qualified therapist in the uk and hopefully you will be able to find it on amazon super easy um hopefully you'll be able to tell your friends and your family about it um we're hoping it's a really easy read a nice easy digestible book broken down into some really
这是Tara和她的朋友及同事建立的，人们可以见面、散步、交谈。它已经成长为一件美妙的事情。但回到书上。我们叫它什么？人们在哪里可以买到它？我们的书叫什么？它叫《Talking Heads：你在英国寻找合格治疗师的指南》，希望你能在亚马逊上非常容易地找到它。希望你能告诉你的朋友和家人。我们希望它是一本非常容易阅读、好消化的书，分为一些非常
easy read sections um and something again that people can just start conversations about there's this book read it or i've read this in a book let's share that with people um and we're really pleased actually aren't we about sometimes it's hard when we've all got busy lives with both parents as well to try and get something completed getting an idea completed but it just shows when something really matters you can do that can't you yeah and you know it felt like launching it in January um is kind of a really good time because often people might be having new year's resolutions they might be thinking what would I want to be different this time next year mental health and kind of wellness goals are kind of common in that and so it felt like a really important time to launch this book and I think
易读的章节。同样，人们可以开始谈论这本书，读过它，或者我在书里读到过这个，让我们和别人分享。我们实际上很高兴，对吧？有时当我们都有忙碌的生活，作为父母，试图完成某件事很难，完成一个想法很难，但这表明当某件事真的很重要时，你可以做到，不是吗？是的，你知道，在1月发布它感觉是一个非常好的时机，因为人们通常会有新年决心，他们可能会想，明年这个时候我想有什么不同？心理健康和健康目标在其中很常见，所以感觉这是发布这本书的一个非常重要的时刻。而且我认为
as well the media started to talk a little bit more about the mental health crisis we have in the UK but also we're seeing more and more and we've had some messages as well ourselves haven't we in conversations with people who have maybe seen someone that they've had concerns about or are just noticing that there's more and more options available to manage your mental health um the rise of coaching in the uk for example is something really important to bring in here um and we just want to help people to navigate all of that information um and when better than the start of the year sometimes after christmas christmas can be a tricky time for many people actually might be a time when people start to reflect as you say make some resolutions or just think about where they might want to make some life choices so
媒体也开始更多地谈论英国的心理健康危机，我们也看到了越来越多——我们自己也收到了一些信息，对吧？在与那些可能见过他们有顾虑的人的谈话中，或者只是注意到有越来越多的选择来管理你的心理健康。例如，英国教练行业的兴起，这是这里非常重要的一点。我们只是想帮助人们导航所有这些信息。还有什么比年初更好的时机呢？有时在圣诞节之后，圣诞节对许多人来说可能是一个棘手的时期，实际上可能是人们开始反思的时候，正如你所说，做出一些决心，或者只是思考他们可能想在哪里做出一些生活选择，所以
perfect time to have a guide to help you with that journey yeah and i know when i was working in the nhs sometimes people would say well if i wanted to find a qualified private therapist where would i go at which point you're not really supposed to make recommendations so this might be a really nice kind of signpost to say actually there's this that's available that can help you through that process because this is not uh it's not high cost price it's not even particularly long as a book you know it's just getting this out there as a robust and valid and useful information source absolutely absolutely um and it's again yeah we both have background in the nhs don't mean sometimes there can be these barriers
这是拥有一个指南来帮助你完成那段旅程的完美时机。是的，我知道当我在NHS工作时，有时人们会说，如果我想找一个合格的私人治疗师，我该去哪里？在这一点上，你真的不应该做推荐，所以这可能是一个非常好的路标，说实际上有这个可用，可以帮助你完成那个过程。因为这不是高成本的价格，它甚至不是一本特别长的书，你知道，它只是把这个作为一个稳健、有效和有用的信息来源发布出来。绝对是，绝对是。而且，是的，我们俩都有在NHS工作的背景，对吧？有时在能够为人们指明正确方向方面可能会有这些障碍，
understandable ones to being able to signpost people in the right direction and it but it is really hard though because sometimes that leaves people in uncertain places and people would know I am mrs risk averse I don't like people being left in a situation where they may end up seeing someone who could put them at risk put their mental health at risk and we both know that there are people out there who are offering services that would come under the umbrella of mental health who should not be doing that and we're big and bold aren't we we don't mind starting conversations about that so you know this isn't about bashing people it's just about making the public aware that some titles for some therapists in the UK are not protected and that anybody can set
可以理解的障碍。但这确实很难，因为有时这会让人们处于不确定的位置。人们会知道我是“风险规避女士”，我不喜欢人们被留在可能最终去看一个可能会让他们处于风险之中、让他们的心理健康处于风险之中的人的情况中。我们都知道外面有人提供属于心理健康范畴的服务，但他们不应该这样做。我们很大胆，对吧？我们不介意开始关于这个的对话。所以，你知道，这不是为了抨击人，这只是为了让公众意识到英国一些治疗师的头衔不受保护，任何人都可以把自己
themselves up as certain types of therapists or talking therapists in the UK which is mind-blowing when you think about it and some people if it's okay to say can hide behind certain names and we might not question those names because they have power behind them so part of the book is helping also to deconstruct some of those titles helping people learn a little bit more about how people can operate so you can spot it so you can be brave and ask those questions about who you're seeing what their qualifications are who they are regulated with who's keeping an eye on the work that they do and what that could look like so we both know don't we that on websites sometimes people can have logos that look super fancy look like they're a member of an organization but actually they are not so we've put some information in there haven't we to help people navigate that
设定为英国的某些类型的治疗师或谈话治疗师，当你想到这一点时，这真是令人震惊。有些人，如果可以这样说的话，可以躲在某些名字后面，我们可能不会质疑这些名字，因为它们背后有力量。所以书的一部分也是帮助解构其中一些头衔，帮助人们更多地了解人们是如何运作的，这样你就可以发现它，这样你就可以勇敢地问那些关于你正在看谁、他们的资格是什么、他们受谁监管、谁在关注他们所做的工作以及那可能看起来像什么的问题。所以我们都知道，对吧？在网站上，有时人们可以有看起来超级花哨的标志，看起来像是某个组织的成员，但实际上他们不是。所以我们在书里放了一些信息，对吧？来帮助人们导航这一点。
which for me is a really really important part of why we're doing this it really is it's just about safety integrity ethics and you know what we think about is efficacious treatment stuff that actually gets results that that helps people achieve their goals whatever whatever that might be. Yeah. And for some people, it's a huge thing, isn't it, to notice that something isn't okay with your emotional health, to think about taking that big, bold and often vulnerable step to find someone to talk to. For people that haven't been through that journey before, it can be a little bit daunting talking to a stranger
对我来说，这是我们为什么这样做的一个非常非常重要的部分。确实是，这只是关于安全、诚信、道德，你知道我们想到的是有效的治疗，真正能产生结果的东西，帮助人们实现他们的目标，无论那可能是什么。是的。对有些人来说，这是一件大事，不是吗？注意到你的情感健康有些不对劲，想到要迈出那一大步，勇敢且通常脆弱的一步去寻找可以交谈的人。对于以前没有经历过那段旅程的人来说，和陌生人交谈可能会有点令人生畏，
about your inner thoughts, your inner feelings. And we want to make sure that people are doing that in a way that's supportive and protective for them because as you quite rightly pointed out at the beginning of the podcast it can be damaging for some people and that damage can take time to repair and sometimes it's irreparable so we want to really help people on that journey so we're both super ethical aren't we we we care about people that's where this book is coming from um and i'm hoping that anybody who's listened to this podcast whether you are someone who is thinking of reaching out for therapy yourself or supporting someone you know or whether you're
关于你内心的想法、内心的感受。我们想确保人们以一种对他们有支持和保护作用的方式这样做。因为正如你在播客开始时非常正确地指出的那样，这对有些人来说可能是破坏性的，那种伤害可能需要时间来修复，有时是无法修复的。所以我们真的想在那个旅程上帮助人们。所以我们俩都超级有道德，对吧？我们关心人们，这就是这本书的来源。我希望任何听过这个播客的人，无论你是正在考虑自己寻求治疗的人，还是支持你认识的人，或者无论你是否是
someone who's in an organization where you regularly maybe get asked to signpost people those are the people that we also want to tap into as well. In a nutshell what do we want people to experience from this? So my background and passion is working in learning disability services and one of the things that I learned working with that wonderful client group is about making informed choices helping people to have the right information to then weigh it up and make the best choice for them. So with this book we are providing you with the information and the understanding you need about how talking therapists can operate in the UK in order for you then to go and check the person or persons that you're looking at to begin. Also second really important point to have conversations
在组织中经常被要求为人们指明方向的人，那些也是我们想要接触的人。简而言之，我们希望人们从中体验到什么？所以我的背景和热情是在学习障碍服务部门工作，我在与那个美妙的客户群体一起工作时学到的事情之一是关于做出明智的选择，帮助人们获得正确的信息，然后权衡它并为他们做出最好的选择。所以通过这本书，我们正在为你提供你需要的信息和理解，关于谈话治疗师如何在英国运作，以便你然后去检查你正在寻找的人或人们。还有第二点非常重要，要进行对话，
to be bold and ask them so if you can take one little nugget from this if you're looking up someone getting to the point where you're going to book an appointment ask them how do I find out who you're registered with and actually go and look them up that's the really important thing being okay with having tricky conversations absolutely so obviously the beauty of a podcast episode is that it's not just for the week that it's launched it's an eternal beautiful beast you know but given that this is you know January um what would be your hopes or wishes or kind of advice for how how our listeners can have a gentler journey in 2024 Tara what would I like for people in 2024 I would like people to be more compassionate to themselves if they are struggling to be okay with having conversations those conversations can be a huge help to you to
要勇敢地问他们。所以如果你能从中得到一点点收获，如果你正在寻找某人，到了你要预约的地步，问他们：我怎么能查到你是向谁注册的？然后真的去查一下，这是非常重要的事情。对进行棘手的对话感到自在。绝对是。所以显然，播客剧集的魅力在于它不仅仅是为了它发布的那一周，它是一个永恒的美丽野兽，你知道。但鉴于这是1月，你对我们的听众在2024年如何拥有更温柔的旅程有什么希望、愿望或建议？Tara，我希望人们在2024年得到什么？我希望人们对自己更富有同情心，如果他们正在挣扎，要对进行对话感到自在。那些对话可以对你产生巨大的帮助，
others it can be that first stepping stone to feeling better about yourselves and as you said quite rightly Marianne we're all about people feeling better aren't we you know that doesn't always have to be in a clinical setting we can start daily conversations I'd like more of that in 2024 checking in on people how are you how are you really following it up and waiting for that response that's my top thing oh that's so nice I do that more now I do it in my own life how are you on the school path and I'm still walking and now making that effort to either not ask if I can't stop or to go how are you really and I've got time to listen or shall
对他人也是。这可能是感觉更好的第一块垫脚石。正如你非常正确地说的，Marianne，我们都是为了人们感觉更好，对吧？你知道，那不一定非要在临床环境中，我们可以开始日常对话。我希望在2024年有更多这样的对话，检查人们的情况，你好吗？你真的好吗？跟进它，等待那个回应，这是我的首要事项。哦，那太好了。我现在更多地这样做。我在我自己的生活中这样做。在学校的小路上，你好吗？我还在走，现在努力要么如果不停止就不问，要么去问“你真的好吗？”我有时间听，或者我们
we make that's really makes such a big difference doesn't it I always use the school path metaphor for all of that stuff that we ask hi how are you and we're still walking we don't stop and maybe we just say hi then yeah if we know we haven't got time that's my thing now if I haven't got time to ask I don't ask now it's really made a big difference. Or if I notice someone, I'll be like, we should catch up. It's been so lovely chatting with you. Thank you for welcoming me back to your audience. And, you know, thank you for sharing your time with my audience too. Looking forward to what 2024 brings for you.
应该安排一下。这真的产生了很大的不同，不是吗？我总是用学校小路的隐喻来形容我们问的所有那些事情，嗨，你好吗？我们还在走，我们不停下来，也许我们只是说嗨。然后，是的，如果我们知道我们没有时间。这就是我现在的事情。如果我没有时间问，我现在就不问了。这真的产生了很大的不同。或者如果我注意到某人，我会说，我们应该聚聚。和你聊天真是太好了。谢谢你欢迎我回到你的听众群。而且，你知道，也谢谢你和我的听众分享你的时间。期待2024年为你带来什么。
Thanks for being such a lovely part of my 2023 and you know providing all this wonderful content that you do absolutely for free often for the people that are in your life um you know and may may 2024 be prosperous for you and for everyone you care about feelings are very mutual people need to hear more about marianne and the fantastic work you do and the fantastic person that you are as well thanks tara that's really kind so yeah looking forward to i'm sure we'll chat again on our podcast in future if people did want to check out talking heads your guide to finding a qualified therapist in the UK. They can do that by checking the links in our show notes, on our socials, or by going straight to Amazon. Thank you so much for
谢谢你成为我2023年如此美好的一部分，你知道，提供所有这些你所做的美妙内容，通常是免费的，为了你生活中的人们。你知道，愿2024年对你和你关心的人繁荣昌盛。感情是非常相互的，人们需要听到更多关于Marianne和你所做的出色工作，以及你也是一个出色的人。谢谢Tara，那真的很客气。所以，是的，期待，我相信我们将来会在我们的播客上再次聊天。如果人们确实想查看《Talking Heads：你在英国寻找合格治疗师的指南》，他们可以通过查看我们节目说明中的链接、我们的社交媒体，或者直接去亚马逊来做到这一点。非常感谢你的
your time, Tara. A pleasure as always. And that's a wrap for this eye-opening episode of both the Aspiring Psychologist podcast and the Adversity Psychologist podcast. A huge thank you to our fantastic co-host, Dr. Tara Quinn-Cherillo, for joining me, Dr. Marianne Trent, in this insightful conversation on finding qualified therapists in the UK. If you have found value in today's discussion, don't forget to hit the like button, subscribe to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast and the Adversity Psychologist podcast for more great content and share your thoughts in the comments. If you're listening on MP3, please do subscribe to the shows. Please also check out the other recommended videos which are on screen if you're watching on YouTube now. Remember, your mental health journey is uniquely yours and the right therapist can make
时间，Tara。一如既往地愉快。这就是《有抱负的心理学家》播客和《逆境心理学家》播客这期令人大开眼界的节目的结尾。非常感谢我们出色的联合主持人Tara Quinn-Cherillo博士加入我，Marianne Trent博士，进行这次关于在英国寻找合格治疗师的深刻对话。如果你在今天的讨论中发现了价值，别忘了点击点赞按钮，订阅《有抱负的心理学家》播客和《逆境心理学家》播客以获取更多精彩内容，并在评论中分享你的想法。如果你在MP3上收听，请务必订阅这些节目。如果你现在正在YouTube上观看，也请查看屏幕上的其他推荐视频。记住，你的心理健康之旅是你独有的，合适的治疗师可以产生
all the difference stay tuned for more engaging episodes and until next time take care of yourselves thanks for being part of my world if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
所有的不同。请继续关注更多引人入胜的剧集，直到下次，照顾好自己。谢谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，主持人是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容真的很有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以到达那里，成为一名临床心理学家没有完美的方式。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，只是为了让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始，你就不会放下这本书。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。